Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in the book of Salah in the chapters
regarding the timings of prayer. Thus
far, we have gone over
the starting and ending times of each of
the five prayers.
And we have discussed as well the
most virtuous times for each of those
five prayers, the best time to make each
of those prayers. Now the author
is going to discuss
the least
the least amount that makes a prayer
valid.
The least amount that makes a prayer
valid. Meaning, as the author puts it,
at what point is the person considered
to have made the prayer on time, like
the very very very last second of time,
where is it? Where's that line in the
sand?
The author says,
[Silence]
Bkari Muslim Abu narrates
this exact point here and that is where
is the ex where at what point is a
person considered to have caught the
prayer? He has caught the prayer at its
very last moment. When is that very last
moment?
if we were to go judged based only on
the principles
of
the general principles of Islam.
The last moment of the prayer when it
would be valid
would be the minimum amount of time
that it would take to make the minimum
amount of valid prayer. What does that
mean? Let's say fudgel for instance.
Fudgel has conditions. It has pillars.
It has obligations. Right? All of those
pillars, conditions, and obligations
need to be made and they need to be made
in two units of prayer, two raqa.
And so naturally based on the general
principles of Islamic patterns, we would
see that the bare minimum would be to
have to make those two raqa at the bare
minimum completely
and the minimum amount of time it would
take to make before the time goes out
because the whole prayer needs to be
made in its time. Prayer is a unit. It's
all one unit and the entire unit of the
prayer is obligated to be made during a
particular amount of time.
Just fasting for instance,
fasting has to be made during a very
specific start and end time. If you were
to make fasting
past its end time and take it out of its
time purposely,
then the fast would be invalid. If a
person said,
"I'm going to start fasting five minutes
after
the fud." This is just 5 minutes. The
rest of the day is all going to be
within the parameters. But these five
minutes, I'm going to make it just five
minutes late.
This would be an invalid fast. Why?
Because the person is purposely taking
it out of its set start and end time.
Likewise is the issue of prayer. But
with prayer, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
from his great mercy
has made it
that the bare minimum
is for a person to make it to the first
rur while the time of that prayer is
still in. If they make it to the first
of the time of that prayer, even if the
rest of the prayer is made in the time
of the next prayer, Allah accepts it.
Allahbar this is a huge mercy from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam tells us as much.
He says here on the authority of Abira,
our prophet tells us whoever catches the
first
of before the sun rises then this person
has is considered to have made
in its time. And whoever catches the
first
rur the first of before the sun sets
then this person is considered to have
made in its time and this narration is
in Bkari Muslim and the scholars of
Islam all agree upon this ruling. There
is no difference of opinion in the
regarding this issue.
And this is from the great mercy of
Allah. And so what does this mean? Let's
say a person is going to make fud. What
time does end right now? Do we know
exactly?
[Arabic recitation]
time. What time? Huh?
All right. And the person starts to pray
at 6:10
and they make it to rur
by 611.
Now the rest of the prayer is going to
be made after 611. Correct? But because
they caught the first,
it's all considered to have been made
before 611.
And this goes for all of the five
prayers.
And not only does it go for the five
prayers, but it goes for all other
prayers as well that are set by a time
such as
etc. All prayers that have a start and
end time, as long as a person catches
the first raka,
then this person is considered to have
caught the prayer in its time. And not
only that, but this ruling is
extrapolated
as well to other parts of salah such as
j. If a person catches the final
of then they have caught.
Meaning if a person were to walk into
the masid in J and catch the last rur
the last
meaning the rur of the second of J. When
the im makes they stand up and make how
many?
Huh? One one raa. I see it.
And that goes with every prayer. Person
comes in in the last and catches the
lastur
of they only have to make three.
A person comes in and catches
after Allah
of the last
how many do they have to pray four they
have to make four now they didn't catch
now they have to make right that's the
opinion of the majority so the point is
is that this is a great allowance of
huge mercy from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
because
we have a part of the prayer a
minimum part of the prayer that was made
during its rightful time and a majority
of the prayer made outside of its time.
So by the patterns and laws of Islam,
this should be rejected because the
majority of it was made outside of
its set times. But Allah goes by the
minority in salah.
He says
and that is a general statement not just
about
but about all prayers that whoever
catches at least one
of any salah then they have caught the
entirety of the prayer. This goes for
its time. This goes, this is a general
rule as I've just explained. And again,
this is of the great and immense
blessing of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Sometimes I feel it's easy to
forget
just how blessed Allah
has made us with respect to our worship.
He gives us five prayers
and those five prayers are worth at
least 50.
And then he accepts the minimum and
gives us the maximum
and he blesses us with allowing us to
make and just the prophets do and
the messengers do. This is a huge b
blessing from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.